this July have your voice be heard I
purged I purged show your support I've
heard because it's my civic duty for the
purge i purge because staying in is an
American this is your emergency
broadcast system announcing the
commencement of the annual purge the
soul of our country is at stake the
center is going to win
she went to mcgrill changes the purge
has to come to an end at the siren all
crimes including murder will be legal
for 12 hours so let's begin lockdown all
emergency services will be suspended
your government thanks you for your
participation we're going to use this
year's purge to do something about that
senator we're being hunted
go go go we are on our own how'd it get
to this what are you doing outside on
purge night senator
come with us there are threats
everywhere is death everywhere
y'all need to see this
being one go survival
think
run I purged to keep my country great
the soul of our country is as
the purge targets the poor and the
innocent the center is going to win he's
going to make real changes to it is a
night that is